on va retrouver philippe pascot écrivain
et auteur du livre mensonge d'état aux
éditions max milo fin il est parce qu
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france vous venez d'entendre
les propos de jean-marie bigard donc a
été exfiltré est pris à partie ce matin
par des gilets jaunes ce qu'on vous
comprenez sa colère je comprends
d'autant plus que j y étais c'est moi
qui ai participé à son exfiltration
et que comme il ya très bien dit au
moins lui il a eu les couilles de venir
j'aimerais bien que plusieurs d'autres
pippa le plein de people est il le même
courage que lui mais comme d'habitude il
ya quinze connard 20 connard anti faf
soi-disant tolérant meucon décidé que
des cabines têtes qui dépassent les fans
et la couper bigard jérôme rodriguez
ils ont un même objectif dégager macro
tous du tout les gens qui veulent faire
des scandales avec des broutilles ont
tort le premier des objectifs c'est de
se débarrasser de l'engeance qui nous
gouvernent de l'engeance qui trichent
avec le peuple français
bigard is by sera peut-être président il
sera peut-être pas président c'est pas
grave moi tout ce qui va à l'encontre et
qui fait bouger le curseur pour se
débarrasser de maquereaux je le soutiens
je soutiens bigard comme je soutiens aux
frais comme je soutiens plein d'autres
gens qui veulent une seule chose que les
gens arrêtent de survivre et que les
gens puissent vivre décemment
ici on a exfiltré vers l'aude de
chercher ddd raison je veux dire externe
à cette polémique entre jean marie
bigard et jérôme regret gaz et sont
apparemment les seuls responsables de
cette polémique il ya eu quand même une
passe d'armes entre ces deux figures
mais c'est de la broutille samantha
c'est rien du tout c'est une erreur de
la et un égard l'écart de l'autre et
puis basta on passe à autre chose et on
avance et on avance parce que le plus
important c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans pour les retraites
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu quelqu'un
qui disait qu'il n'ait touché de la
retraite mais hier ils ont mal géré la
crise du coc vide et on oublié de parler
de tout ce qui s'est passé depuis avec
le co vide
moi je suis en train de référencer tous
les décrets tous les machins qui sont en
train de passer mais c'est une folie les
vingt ans qui vont venir vous savez que
on a quand même fait de l'auteur
asie déguisés dans les ehpad vous savez
quand même que demain les retraites vont
être sabordé qu'il ya plus de code du
travail qu'il ya plus de sécurité
sociale qui continuent à verser des
dividendes énormes au riche et le plus
le plan de relève le relance ne sert
uniquement que pour les gens qui sont en
haut de la pyramide ceux qui sont en bas
continuent à crever donc la petite
histoire jérôme bigard qui a été
alimentée par des mecs payer sans doute
par macro pour venir le bordel
moi non ces propos n'engagent que vous
signez pasco pour parler justement alors
nommé pour évoquer justement les forces
de l'ordre pour évoquer les forces de
l'ordre les policiers aussi vivent aussi
dans des moments difficiles on le sait
ils sont mobilisés ils sont mobilisés
encore une fois aujourd'hui il ya une
centaine d'interpellations depuis ce
matin sur ce dispositif sécuritaire est
ce que vous le jugez disproportionné par
rapport à cette mobilisation des gilets
jaunes mais non seulement je juge
disproportionnée mais il ya deux
discours il ya un discours qui dit les
gilet jaune ne pèse plus rien les
citoyens ne pèse plus rien les
manifestations il ya plus personne ayant
encore plus de policiers que d'habitude
dans la rue donc expliquer moi j'ai du
mal à comprendre qu'on met encore plus
de policiers alors qu'il ya moins de
manifestations il ya moins de
manifestants donc ça c'est déjà un non
sens en plus le truc a sorti darmanin de
ne pas floutés les policiers maintenant
quand on va les passer à la télé mais
c'est une porte ouverte à certaines
bavures et encore une fois je le dis
devant vous moi je respecte la police
j'aime la police par contre il ya
certains policiers qui profitent du
système et du fait qu'on les laisse
faire qui en profitent pour faire
n'importe quoi il ya certains policiers
il n'y a pas de honte à le dire qu'ils
sont quasiment sadique pendant les
manifestations
mais c'est pas l'ensemble des policiers
lancent en classe et ça c'est des
foutaises
il s'agit de l'effrontée s'assure plus
on va les plus on va les flous témoin
pour aller repérer c'est vachement
pratique pour pour favoriser les bavures
flouter les gens fait qu'on puisse pas
les reconnaître
or non seulement ils n'auront pas de
riom non seulement ils n'auront pas de
rio mais en plus on verra pas leur
visage ça va être vachement facile pour
les retrouver je voudrais que josiane
quand même qu'il ya plein de jugement
qui sont passés
des policiers est pas tous les policiers
sur certains policiers qui ont fait des
malversations sur des manifestants qu'on
n'a pas qu à inculper parce que les
juges ont dit mais on n'a pas l'oreille
on peut pas savoir qui c'est alors en
plus quand ils vont être floutés ces
gens là mais on les retrouvera jamais
c'est la porte ouverte à certains
salissent et pas tous les policiers
parce que 95% des policiers sont des
gens bien mais il ya 5 % qui font honte
à la police qui font honte aux gendarmes
et qui sont des véritables ça nique sur
les manifestations et ces propos
n'engagent que moi bien entendu alors
sur le fond des revendications sur
l'essence même des mouvements des gels
et jolie a eu un confinement il ya eu
une trêve estivale vous même vous faites
votre retour peut-être sur les plateaux
de télévision avec mon frère tu es
france
justement qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis
ces derniers mois pour le mouvement mais
gilet jaune mais malheureusement
samantha rien n'a changé est ce que les
gens vivent mieux
est ce que l'essence a baissé est ce que
le frigidaire est toujours remplie est
ce que quelque part les gens au plus de
moyens pour exister
est ce que des gens comme jean cosnay
vivent encore dans leur voiture alors
qu'il travaille et ben oui y'a rien qu'a
changé depuis le 17 novembre 2017
monsieur macron a fait semblant
d'écouter mais monsieur macro et sourd
monsieur macro fait semblant de dire
qu'il est ouvert mais monsieur macro est
complètement fermée à la population et
c'est pour ça que les gilets jaunes sont
encore dans la rue mais c'est plus que
les gilets jaunes c'est aussi des
citoyens
on dépasse le cadre des gilets jaunes
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est l'ensemble
des citoyens qui vont finir par
descendre dans la rue parce que ça
commence à devenir intolérable de ne
plus pouvoir respirer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on en est au stade
samantha où on ne peut même plus
respirer c'est qu'ils ont trouvé un
autre système pour coincer les gens nous
empêcher de respirer et si tu essayes de
respirer on te file 135 euros damende
alors la sécurité c'est bien mais la
sécurité à outrance à des fins
politiques ça c'est pas bien et c'est ce
qui est en train de faire monsieur matte
de pandémie
deux regarde décontamination de cause le
19 mai sa montage
écoutez bien ce que je viens de dire moi
je suis pas contre les mesures de
protection de la population
je suis contre des mesures qui ne sont
que des mesures politiques politique
comment ça se fait qu'aujourd'hui je
vais vous expliquer on ait le droit de
circuler sans problème dans un dans un
avion se payant en côte à côte et c'est
d'avoir des dents trop le métro de façon
bondé de façon bondé tous les matins
tous les matins et puis qu'on n'ait pas
le droit de se retrouver dans une salle
de spectacle en lien ci s'est pas séparé
d'un rang chacun il ya quand même des
non sens dans la façon dont ces gens
gèrent les la pandémie comment ça se
fait que quelque part on accuse des
médicaments qui cousent dozos 12 euros
d'être des mauvais le mega man et que
par contre on fait tout ce qu'il faut
pour des médicaments qui coûtera entre
400 et 600 euros
comment ça se fait qu'on ferait favorise
la les big pharmas et qu'on refuse parce
que moi je les vues sur les masques par
exemple refuser que des gens en fabrique
en france quand je vois que les basques
qui sont donnés aux enseignants
aujourd'hui qu'on soit disant été envoyé
aux enseignants sont des masques qui
sont même pas réglementaire et quand
vous soufflez vous happe hervé que ça
passe à travers succès des masques qui
quelque part ne sont même pas aux normes
c'est normal ça merci à vue et entendu
samantha propos n'engagent que moi
merci à vous fini de pasco je rappelle
que vous êtes écrivain auteur du livre
mensonge d'état aux éditions max milo